grab your motorcycles we've got a new
episode of Reacher which means we're in
for one heel of a good time that's right
episode 4 offers new insight into what
exactly am is selling how it could lead
to a catastrophic terrorist attack and
more clues that hint at one of the team
members being a bad guy keep in mind I
haven't read the book so there will be
no book spoilers in this review so let's
not waste any time and get right into it
last episode saw Reacher and the Gang
quietly break into New Age Technologies
the car belonged to one of their
employees I was returning at a nearby
Diner the team goes over all the new
information they uncovered including
that former special investigations unit
member Tony Swan was working for new age
as assistant director of security so he
was just below Shane Langston the man
hellbent on killing Reacher and his team
now Reacher is adamant that Swan isn't
in on this whole conspiracy rather that
he's a victim something Neely isn't too
sure of you want Swan to be innocent
because you hired him into the 110 we
find out that the guy Reacher threw a
barbecue at was also on this security
team so Reacher and the Gang intend to
hunt down all these new age workers in
the hopes of getting answers meanwhile
Russo the most over-the-top New Yorker
I've ever seen is chewed out for
Reacher's escapades at New Age his
Lieutenant wants to know what Reacher
found out could this be because he's
secretly working with new age or is he
merely doing his duty as a cop where
things start to get interesting are
these emails between Swan and New Age
director of operations Marlo burns the
woman who gave Dixon and Neely the
address of the home where the team would
later be ambushed Swan references loving
a Jimmy Hendrick album specifically song
number six titled a little wi this is
odd since the team knows Swan hates hris
no Skinner no Zeppelin No Hendrick no
who I like my music lighter little wi
was the code word for a ninef figure
Federal defense contract between New Age
and the US government but in order for
this deal to go through its funding
would need to be approved by Congress
meanwhile we have this flashback of the
special investigations unit celebrating
a victory in their missing fuel case in
the first three episodes Dixon and
Reacher found out that several military
aircraft had gone through more than
their relegated amount of fuel meaning
something on these aircrafts was causing
them to burn more this turned out to be
unaccounted for heroin Military Officers
were smuggling out of Afghanistan and it
looks like they made their first big
bust 48 big bricks of heroin now the
writers are really trying to paint Swan
as a bad guy here not only does Swan
talk about how it's unfair these
criminals make more than all their
pensions combined with one of these
shipments but an entire brick of heroin
is conveniently found unaccounted for in
the back of his truck was it an honest
mistake or was he purposely hiding it in
present day Denver our International
arms dealer am has had to get creative
in acquiring new identities after reach
in the gang found his list of aliases
he's found this doctor who looks a lot
like him so he's got to die so that am
can steal his identity Reacher continues
to look into little wi and the senator
who pushed for its funding but instead
of going for the senator himself they go
for an easier Target the person who
drafted the bill this is the legislative
director Daniel Boyd this guy has a
history of DUIs and romps with sex
workers making him a good Target for
blackmail and it just so happens he'll
be in town for a special fundraising
event at the symphony but if they're
going to Blackmail this guy they're
going to need some drugs so Reacher
takes out the same drug dealer he did a
few episodes ago you'd think this guy
would learn by now meanwhile neie and
Dixon head to Marlo Burns's house in
search of answers the place looks
chaotic as if someone was in a hurry to
get the hell out of there the cabinets
and closets are open clothes strewn
about and Marlo has left behind a bag
full of money why would someone leave
this behind am continues his obsession
with comic books and young children as
he uses his new identity to purchase a
rental car do you know why I love comic
books so much I love the beginning of
this dress shopping scene because
odonnell is just creepily checking out
dresses and while Reacher thinks they
all look like on top of a
wedding cake he still has the hots for
Dixon and Dixon will have to look her
best if she's going to woo her Target at
the symphony it doesn't take long for
Dixon to lure Daniel out to the back of
her car for a little booger sugar
allowing him to get arrested by none
other than Oscar Finley you may remember
Oscar as margraves Chief detective in
season 1 in fact it's pretty funny that
when Oscar introduces himself to Reacher
and odonnell Reacher refers to himself
as detective margrave the location most
of season 1 is set odonnell is referred
to as Blake a nod to Blind Blake the
blues musician who allegedly died in
margrave but before we get there we have
to discuss the new development on these
numbers found on orosco's secret USB
last episode Dixon theorized that that
the numbers are a Six-Day work week over
the course of 7 months Reacher Builds on
this theorizing these numbers are also a
tally and if you add these numbers all
up there are only
1,547 total events accounted for out of
2,197 leaving 650 unaccounted remember
that 650 is the amount of Rosco kept
seeing over and over again 650 at 100K
each in episode 2 the man dealing with
am says oh 650 will be in the truck so
it looks like am has whatever these
items are and it isn't until Daniel's
interrogated that we find out just what
we're dealing with now I got to bring
this up because I thought it was a bit
weird throughout the first four episodes
odonnell keeps getting messages from his
family including one in this episode
that goes straight to his burner phone
which he brushes off stating that he
must have accidentally given his kids
that number this is extremely fishy and
it makes me think he's one of the bad
guys he's probably not talking to his
family at all remember that he was found
in Reacher ne's trashed hotel room and
several times throughout this episode
tried to paint Tony Swan as a traitor
but for those of you who haven't read
the book let me know what you think in
the comments Reacher and odonnell
interrogate Daniel in the hopes of
finding out everything they can about
little wi and it doesn't take long for
Daniel to squeal little wi was the code
name for an anti-missile software to
protect commercial aircrafts from attack
but Boyd was approached by New Age who
stated this technology could be tweaked
to create powerful portable surface to a
Weaponry that could hit its Target every
time you fire you hit your target period
this new tech could prove very useful
for the US Military and very lucrative
for New Age the only problem they need
approved funding So Daniel and his
Senator buried the proposal in a
thousand Page Long Bill where no one
would read it and voila it got approved
it's implied that both he and the
senator got paid under the table for
this because that's just how things work
in Washington Daniel isn't too concerned
about this technology because it's in
the hands of us Americans but am and New
Age may have other plans outside Denver
am and this guy have an agreement that
these weapons are not to be used on us
soil to which am responds he'd never
harm anyone which we know is a lies as
he just goes around the country killing
people but Daniel's big Revelation is
that new age has two facilities not one
the facility Reacher broke into at the
end of episode 3 only handled the
software while the facility in Denver
has the actual hardware for these
weapons to work these software and
Hardware need to be combined this is why
Shane Langston has been working with Am
Shane has the software am has the
hardware but it still leaves the
question why did Shane need to hire am
if his company New Age already owned
both parts we don't know the answer to
that just yet but maybe it was to make
it look like their parts were stolen or
maybe Shane has gone Rogue and is doing
his own thing with a bigger picture
starting to form it looks like neie and
Dixon will go off to Denver to
investigate this second facility while
Reacher and O'Donnell are off to DC to
consult with Homeland Security Reacher's
brother the one who died in season 1
used to work for Homeland Security and
some of his contacts may be of help but
it wouldn't be an episode of Reacher
without some good oldfashioned ass
kicking Shane has hired the most
delightful motorcycle gang to put an end
to Reacher but as we all know do not
mess with the special investigators they
may quick work of these fools and
Reacher waste no time getting in touch
with their boss telling him exactly what
he wants I want to throw you out of a
helicopter I can't wait for more
episodes of Reacher and to see where the
story takes us I hope you'll consider
liking and subscribing I plan on
covering the whole season thanks for
watching and until next time remember he
was stopped by barbecue he died from
trans
fats